infections so friendly so pointed resist
the temptation of starting to discuss
what you said figure out in the idea
that cabin or would not be literary text
my friend John Carroll affair I hope you
provide him someday one of the great
German is translate your fingermarks
fellow named John has brilliantly I
don't think he's the only one who have
done it willingly compared to a bday and
more recently I found to my amazement
and delight and say the celebrated
phrase in Marx's capital the
expropriation of the expropriated that
everybody knows which I had already some
time ago traced back to a Masonic
passage in
in Isaiah in the Bible where it is said
and you will oppress your oppressive as
its exact equivalent the passage in Moby
Dick were kept in a hab insulting the
way in in advance exclaims and hi I i
will now dismember my dismember
well thank you so much for the
invitation and credibly grateful to the
mezzo process once again and the French
department and the icrs for giving me
the opportunity to talk but Europe and
its crisis here today and I thank you
for coming at such short notice moment
in the day in which i know that most of
you have many occupations I want to
before even I
start reading my texts allow me to
remove phrase which i just found in fact
from an article published a few months
ago August 29 in the washington post by
when on American pundit Charles Koch
Chang how do you pronounce corrosion
culture the European Union is dying not
a dramatic or sudden death but once so
slow and steady that we may look across
the Atlantic one day soon and realize
that the project of European integration
that we've taken for granted over the
past half century is no more and then
come several pages of illustration of
that idea
I indeed suspect and you see that I'm
not the only one in doing so that a
dramatic event has been taking place at
some point during the past month which I
would describe as the end of the
European political project or the
project of transforming Europe into the
post national entity within given
borders and through the cooperation of
various nation states which shared a
common history admittedly complex and
conflictual and also as a consequence
could unite around a certain idea this
was not a project of suppressing the
constituting nations but of limiting
their sovereignty in the name of a
greater interdependence II and
solidarity it has now collapsed whether
this end is a person or negative
phenomenon both in terms of the
interests of the European populations
and people's whether it's marked an
absolute reversal of the main tendencies
of contemporary history or a shift in
the balance of forces between elements
which always opposed it or buy it excuse
me a four-seater was too quickly between
elements which were in favor of the
emergence of a new political entity
called Europe or the European Union and
elements which always opposed it or buy
it for different reasons and with
different interests or indeed the simple
manifestation in the open of a situation
which had already been
before in particular at the moment of
the failure of the grand constitutional
project in 2005 weather finally this end
is just the end of a political project
in the narrow institutional sense of the
term leaving in place and perhaps
liberating the capacities of other
elements of the European construction
such as the economy in the capture the
society even the bureaucracy or it also
means that all these elements will find
themselves increasingly paralyzed and
dissociated which I tend to believe
could be the case but I certainly don't
have any certainty in this respect these
are all questions that I offer for
reflection and discussion supposing that
you could agree on the fact of the event
itself or the accomplished end of the
European political project but of course
there's nothing edited here and since my
conviction on this point was first
formed in the moment of the so-called
Greek crisis in the last spring I would
need first to return to my reflections
at this time which I expressed in the
form of a set of theses published in the
French web John or internet journal
media paths and also
he on the English newspaper The Guardian
and now if you are interested to be
found on the online journal theory and
events published by the johns hopkins
university press vol 3 issue number two
of two thousand and ten now which Jesus
did I propose
first teases was that the financial
crisis whose effects were dramatically
affecting the Greek budgets and as a
consequence threatening the European
banking and monetary system was only the
beginning with in one single month we
had witnessed Prime Minister Papandreou
his revelation of the real Greek Greek
debt which had been up every day or more
new revelations about that which had
been manipulated by his predecessor with
the help of Goldman Sachs the
announcement of his country's inability
to repay hugely increased credit
interests an expensive European rescue
loan offered to him in his country on
the condition of devastating budget cuts
all this soon followed by the downgraded
rating of the Portuguese and Spanish
dance a threat of the value and the very
existence of the euro currency the
creation of a European security fund
fund worth 750 billion euros the Central
European banks decision against explicit
rules to bail out some sovereign debt in
case of necessity and the announcement
of budget austerity measures in several
member states these were the latest
episodes are the crisis and
four episodes of crisis which had
started two years before with the
collapsing of the US housing credit and
would seem to forecast others until
today they remind us that there is more
than ever a risk of financial crash
provoked by the huge amount of rotten
stocks which have been accumulated over
the last decade through the combination
of unwarranted loans and the
transformation of credit-default
insurances into financial products for
speculation they're becoming recoverable
deaths like the blackjack in a card game
what in france we called mystically are
changing place and denomination and the
states that is the taxpayers can't catch
up indefinitely the short-term
speculation was now targeting the
currencies and the public deaths the
euro appeared and perhaps still is I'm
not an expert the weak link in the chain
and so did Europe itself for many
serious economists there can be little
doubt that catastrophe consequences are
coming
the second thesis was that the Greek
protest popular protest was and remains
essentially justified a first immediate
effect of the toxic remedy the pride of
the Greek crisis was the angry protest
of the Greek population it is debated
whether this should be seen as a coward
denial of the populations own
responsibility or no more healthy
rejection of an unjust collective
punishment leaving aside the criminal
episodes which have interfered at some
point it seems to me that the protest of
the Greek was fully justified for at
least three reasons first we have been
witnessing completely insane
denunciation of the whole Greek people
not only in European journals and forums
but also in other parts of the world
including the US the corruption and the
lives of red editions whose
beneficiaries as elsewhere as everywhere
are essentially the rich cultivating tax
evasion on a grand scale were blamed on
the people are such indiscriminately
second once again the government had
betrayed in electoral promises without
any form of democratic debate last
Europe did not display any real
solidarity towards one of its member
states but imposed on it the cursive
roots of the International Monetary Fund
which protect not the nation's but the
vast and promised deep and endless
recession most serious economists agreed
that this would spread the crisis
possibly needing even more innovatively
to a default of the Greek Treasury in
any case rising the already high rates
of an employment especially the same
routes where imposed on other countries
whose rating on the financial market
could become downgraded at any moment
the in famous pics portugal ireland
greece and spain which incidentally was
exactly what the overlooks party was
asking for the third teases was that we
should consider all these phenomena and
tendencies not as the inevitable effects
of economic constraints more or less
inevitable but as politics which is
hiding its name
the Greek were the first victims but
they can hardly be the last of a
politics of rescuing the European
currency who strategy dispositions
mainly imposed at the time by Germany
but also backed by others are first and
foremost a general restriction of public
expenses and in addition a rather mild
control of speculation and the free
movements of hedge funds and traders
already announced several times after
the crisis of the subprimes and the
actual of virtual crash of the u.s.
banks of some big US bank in 2008 to
this New Keynesian economists I would
return to this added another request to
move as rapidly and as completely as
possible towards the creation of a
European economy government especially
through the unification of tax policies
possibly also correlating and enhancing
industrial investments for want of such
measures they claimed a single European
currency would prove unsustainable none
of these measures indeed are purely
technical they are entirely political
measures which all citizens ought to be
allowed to debate because each and every
of us will be affected
by the outcome however to the extent
that it exists the discussion remains
deeply biased because essential
determinations are hidden or pushed
aside any policy of defending or
devaluing the currency in the conjecture
of crisis leads to a radical alternative
either it subjects the economic and
social decisions to the power of the
financial markets including its rating
criteria working as self-fulfilling
prophecies and it's a need to be
absolute wise judgments or it adds to
the capacity of the state and more
generally the public institutions to
limit the markets instability and grant
long-term economic interests a primacy
over short speculation but it cannot be
both in its current form under the
influence of the dominant social forces
the European construction may have used
some degree of institutional
harmonization this is the second end
I suggest is brushed aside may have
produced some degree of institutional
harmonization and generalize the
protection of some fundamental rights
which is certainly not negligible
although often more verbal than real
witness the recent vicissitudes of the
European would be indignant of friends
on the issue of Romani rough roaming
freedom of circulation but contrary to
the stated goes it has not produced any
convergent evolution of national
economies a zone of shared prosperity
far from some countries are dominant
others are dominated with respect to
shares in the marqus or concentration
of financial capital or industrial
autonomy the people's may not have
antagonistic interests but the nations
and the states increasingly do third any
Keynesian strategy to generate public
trust in the economy rests on three
independent pillars a stable currency
certainly a rational system
taxes but also is social policy aiming
at full employment or as full as
possible and increasing the popular
consumption to sustain the demand this
third aspect is systematically ignored
in most current commentaries obviously
not by chance the false ceases that I
believe to be relevant to the situation
concerned the real trends of
globalization underpinning the visible
manifestations of the crisis all this
debate concerning the Euro monetary
system which let us not forget some
important European countries still still
don't want to join including the United
Kingdom but also Sweden and Poland and
the future of Europe would remain
entirely abstract unless it is
articulated to the real trends of
globalization precisely those strands
which the financial crisis will
powerfully accelerate unless they are
politically addressed by the people's
which they affect and their governments
how can we summarize them
first we're witnessing a transition from
one form of international competition to
another no longer mainly the Commission
among productive capitals but a
combination among national territories
which use tax exemptions and pressure on
the wages of Labor and ever-increasing
insecurity of jobs to attract more
floating Cavanaugh's than their
neighbors now whether you Raph works as
an effective system of solidarity among
its members to protect them from
so-called systemic risk or pushed by
powerful states who are momentarily more
efficient or better protected from
market fluctuations simply sets a
theoretical framework to promote a
greater degree of competition among the
member states and their citizens this
will determine the future of Europe
politically socially and culturally but
there is a second tendency which must be
taken into account namely a
transformation of the international
division of labor which radically
destabilizes the distribution of
employment in the world this is a new
global structure we know where north and
south east and west all denominations
which
will last forever of course are now
exchanging their places for Europe or
most of it if not counteracted it will
entail a brutal increase of inequalities
a collapsing of the middle classes the
shrinking of skilled jobs a displacement
of so-called volatile productive
industries a regression of welfare and
social rights the destruction of
cultural industries and general public
services this is why resistances against
supranational political integration
which believed to protect the
sovereignty of the states will in fact
we can the defenses of each singular
nation they will also precipitate a
return to the ethnic conflicts which the
European construction wanted to overcome
forever this is in fact already well
underway however and it's one of the
points on which caption is eager to
exist however it is also clear that a
greater political integration of Europe
cannot become created from above by some
bureaucratic decision it requires
Democratic participation
and advances in each country and the
continent as such this leads me to the
fifth thesis which takes the form of a
question admittedly a risky one which
concerns the meaning of so-called
populist movements in Europe is it
essentially apparel for democracy or
could it become also a resource we
cannot but ask the question is this
crisis the beginning of the end for the
European Union a construction that had
started 50 years ago on the basis of an
age-old utopia but now crucian able to
fulfill its promises I'm afraid that the
answer unfortunately is yes as I said
already a moment ago sooner or later
this will be inevitable and possibly not
without some violent term on unless
unless it finds the capacity to start
again on radically new basis Europe is a
dead political project but the breaking
of European Union put inevitably
it's people's to the hazards of
globalization to an even greater degree
conversely a new foundation of Europe
does not guarantee any success but at
least it gives her a chance of gaining
some geopolitical maverick in her own
benefit and perhaps the benefit of
others with one condition however that
all the challenges involved in the idea
of an original form of post National
Federation Confederation I don't mind
the term are seriously and courageously
met and as the failure failure of
previous attempts would seem to
demonstrate they are anything but you it
is a question of setting up a common
public authority which is neither a
state nor nation-state even at a bigger
scale nor the simple governance of
politicians and experts of securing
genuine equality among the nations thus
fighting against reactionary
nationalisms whether on the side of the
strong all the side of the week and
above all of reviving democracy in the
european space thus resisting the
current processes of d democratization
or as I
said some years ago statism without a
state produced by near liberalism and
the colonization of its administration's
by a bureaucratic cast which is also
partially the source of the corruption
in the public markets something of yours
should have been long acknowledged there
will be no progress towards federalism
in Europe the one that is now advocated
by some and rightly so in my opinion in
parenthesis I disagree in this respect
with prominent French analysts including
on the left in the goalie stand Mitchell
and East traditions such as former
Minister of Foreign Affairs affair
between the one who coined the name
hyperpower for the United States with
whom I recently debated this issue in
the French door code Philadelphia
Magazine so there will be no progress to
its federalism in Europe if democracy
itself does not progress beyond the
existing forms the Lowell that increase
influence for the people's in the
supranational institutions
does this mean that in order to reverse
the course of recent history to shake
the letter G of a decaying political
construction we need something like
European populism in other terms the
simultaneous movement or a peaceful
insurrection of popular masses who will
be voicing their anger as victims of the
crisis against its others and
beneficiaries and calling for the
control from below over the secret
beginnings and occult deals made by
markets Bam's and states yes indeed
there is in fact no other name with
which we can call a becoming political
of the people i agree that it can lead
to other catastrophes which is why we
need strong constitutional rules to be
observed and above all political forces
to emerge again in the European arena
who introduced the culture of
uncompromising democratic ideals and
imaginary into this post national
populism this of course makes very
5th set of kindness of conditions but
the risk is greater it seems to me in a
felling nationalism to evade in
whichever for this leads me to my final
thesis again in the form of a question
where is the European left in some parts
of the world including this one forces
aiming at the kind of peaceful
insurrection that I have just mentioned
were traditionally called the left but
the European left also is now bankrupt
nationally ends transnationally in the
broader political space stretching it
across borders that is now relevant it
has lost every capacity to express
social struggles or lounge emancipatory
movements it has surrendered to the
dogmas and rational ease of neoliberal
of alexey consistently it has been
ideologically disintegrated deprived of
any strong popular support ning me the
left political party
today would have social support those
parties which represent it's nominally
on now powerless spectators and
commentators of the crisis for which
they offer no specific and connective
response they have remained passive
after the financial shock in 2008 sin
passive when the International Monetary
Fund resides which in other times on
other continents they had vigorously
criticized Argentina etc were imposed on
Greece passive again when it was
proposed to rescue the Euro at the
expense of wage laborers and ordinary
consumers and approved unable to launch
a public debate under possibility and
the needs of a Europe of solidarity we
may well wonder in these conditions what
is going to happen when the crisis
enters its next in select next to be
next phases when national policies
increasingly repressive lose their
social contents of their remaining
social alibis there will be protest
movements almost certainly but then we
find themselves isolated possibly they
will become deviated towards violence or
recuperated by racism and xenophobia
which are already searching or around us
in the end
will produce more powerlessness more
despair this is tragic since the
capitalists and nationalists right
itself now on the offensive is also
strategically divided it was clear when
stopping public deficits was pitted
against investment policies and it will
be even more the case when the very
existence of common European
institutions is at stake there was an
occasion to see a strong word to say
about but the question also when it was
not said by the left but the question
also concerns the intellectuals what
should and could be a democratically
elaborated political action against the
crisis at the European level walking
walking excuse me on both legs economic
administration social policy eliminating
corruption and reducing the inequalities
which faster is restructuring the
restructuring deaths and defining common
objectives in order to legitimize
transfers of tax resources between
mutually interdependent nations it is
the task of progressive intellectuals
whether they see themselves as
reformists or revolutionaries to discuss
this subject and take risks and here if
I had time of course I should
the parentheses which could be long to
say that there are indeed initiatives in
that sense but they come from
individuals or from very limited group
of intellectuals however not deprived of
course of influence and clout in some
cases two examples come immediately to
my mind which I want to one of them is
the so-called manifesto of European
concerned citizens of manifesto for new
Europe signed by ash I mean another
Saskia Sassen in particular which is in
that University has posted it in fact on
the so-called half the Huffington
so published in the New Statesman and
other places and the second one which is
more recent the so-called manifesto of a
pawn of the afford economists this is
most effective threat to the region but
also exists in English you can find it
on a very interesting test these were
the questions that I was trying to
formulate a few months ago and wanted to
publicly discussed in the wake of the
Greek crisis incidentally this crisis is
not over it has only disappeared from
the television screens four months later
I keep thinking that they are innovative
or even if I repeat I can admit that I
have not found for each of them the best
possible formulation for this reason I
will try in the second part I talk to
add clarifications and therefore further
nourish the discussion on two points
which certainly are not the only ones
which need such clarification they
concern the relationship between
democracy and populism and the
reciprocity of
and determination let me start with each
your optimism which is probably the most
dedicated especially when you speak
before an audience which I suspect
broken shares the values and historical
perspectives of what a moment ago I call
the left incidentally the debates about
the oscillations in meaning in the
meaning scope and effects of optimism is
perhaps easier to start on this side of
the Atlantic in a country where the
category has a long and complex history
and remains used in very contradictory
ways i noticed that president obama was
called populists when he launched an
attack
tagged against the tyranny of or street
and I noticed of course that the term is
also e to qualify I have used this term
I'm going to go in complete awareness of
the terrible images which characterize
its use and meaning I believe that they
belong to the essence of the political
indicating an intrinsic risk that
politics which wants to escape
abstraction and take into account real
forces acting in a given conjuncture can
never avoid they also point at the issue
on which democratic politics must
concentrate its efforts both in terms of
mobilization and clarification the
popular movement which today is so
dramatic so dramatically missing must be
reconstructed it must also indeed in the
middle of dangerous circumstances
acquire a moral and intellectual
capacity to resist certain deviations
without forgetting the lessons of tragic
experiences in the past in the debate
which is perhaps starting about the
renovation of the left and the
resurrection of politics of the European
level other contributors prefer to
insist on a civic commitment rather than
a need of
anism which i perfectly understand since
i have myself long advocated in other
places an extension of the category of
citizenship in the active sense
including its ethical dimension at the
trans national level but i do believe
that we need to use both notions let me
try to explain political theorists but
it should be political theorist and
philosopher historic low well known
certainly audience has insisted that the
dominant conception of politics
stigmatizes the notion of populism not
only because of its association with
nationalism and even racism but because
the political institution is viscerally
opposed to the direct to any direct
intervention of popular masses in the
field of politics which would so we're
told distort the play of constitutional
rules and put democracy itself at risk
in the eyes of the privileged elite such
a notion is also an obstacle which makes
it more difficult to adopt and carry on
unpopular policies so what very often
the category populism designates while
referring to innumerable examples of
demagogic and dictatorial regimes
serving as alibi perhaps the name Chavez
last example he's also in fact a
supplement or in excess of democracy
with respect to its early got cake and
elitist definitions which involves
active participation protests campaigns
extra-parliamentary spontaneous or
organized mass movement and this country
just as europe is not poor in records
for such moments and movements but in
the absence of such movements democracy
soon becomes an abstract word if not a
mystification democracy requires the
crystallization the visibility of the
demos of the multitude in other terms
the majority which it officially
represents not to suppress the
parliamentary and representative
institutions in general the division of
powers the protection of individual
rights and the rights of minorities but
to recreate an equilibrium of social
forces the possibility of more
egalitarian access to power compensating
the influence of economic power wealth
social relations based on expertise and
professional hierarchies and family ties
and academic solidarity's in short on
class membership the current
developments in our European countries
especially in the field of economic
social policies eloquently illustrate
the consequences of the complete
imbalance of forces between the early
gawky and the majority nobody is really
able to dispute the decisions which are
proposed or imposed by governments of
global transnational administration's
whose main effect is to transfer unto
the ordinary people the burden of deaths
which have been generated by the
anarchic speculation of the markets or
the irresponsible budgetary decisions of
governments this is generally designated
euphemistically as a youth as a
democratic deficit of our officially
democratic regimes which was blatant in
the Greek case but is no less observable
when other European governments
including the French the Spanish the
German the British adopt austerity
policies which are very far from the
programs to which they had committed
themselves at the time of the elections
in particular because they neglect the
dramatic questions of poverty and
employment I should avoid
misunderstandings here nobody who is
serious when dispute the fact that
critical circumstances may impose
changes even reversals of political
orientations but you cannot consider
that it is democratic to carefully
exclude the population from the
information and the discussion when it
comes to determining the content and the
extension of the changes take the
example of the conflict on retirement
age and pensions today in France which
has equivalents in other countries by
the way if you read this morning you're
on time there is a an editorial
precisely on that France the unions and
fiscal reality would be worth discussing
and what holds at the national level is
even truer at the supranational or
communitarian level where some of the
most decisive measures are taken for
want of a European democracy including
debates in the population and the
emergence of parties in the broad sense
mobilizing citizens across the borders
you only have what you only have or
negotiations know to say bargaining
among national governments and
politicians got much more interested in
flattering the prejudices of the
electoral basis
encouraging their actual participation
we have to do here with a permanent
floor of the European Union perhaps it
is not the only cause why the Democratic
life within each nation tense now to
degenerate or become blocked but
certainly it does nothing to improve the
situation governments I don't believe
that the amount of democracy in the
national and supranational arena is
something like a system of communicating
vases if you have more less democracy at
the European level you have more on the
national level and the conversion is
just the opposite when you have her last
at the supranational level you also have
less at the national level and
conversely this is what we observe
governments use the European
institutions when they find it
convenient in particular to picture of
the political choices as technical
imperatives or constraints imposed by
the supranational bureaucracy but they
nor or downplay them when something like
a transnational public sphere seems to
be emerging which they would not control
there was never a question for the
European Parliament to seriously examine
the financial bailout or the
articulation of monetary and budgetary
policies in Europe the parliament in
this sense is even less than an advisory
body this is a fear or as my colleague
and friend Jacques Mossler we put it a
hatred of democracy which proves
terribly self-destructed in the long run
it leads to complete loss of legend
for politics the government or and
representative institutions themselves
whether at the National on the European
level since the two as I said just a
minute ago cannot be separated for that
reason it has become the task of the
people's which taken together a form of
virtual demos at the European level to
revive the Democratic principle without
which there is no possibility of a
legitimate government and of State Board
institutions which means that the
national people's must learn to reject
the policies based on the continuation
of privileges or even their development
in the context of the crisis this is why
I spoke of the need of a European
populism which is now the opposite of
civic values and commitments but it's
complementary side in a given critical
conjecture in other terms I'm not I am
far from ignoring that the most visible
and active forms of populism today in
Europe rapidly expanding throughout the
continent have nothing to do with a
peaceful insurrection of citizens coming
from different countries in the name of
democracy in order to remove the early
gothic structures as we know it is maybe
a nationalistic and local populism
strongly xenophobic even potentially
murderous with respect to any
conditions the migrants especially those
who come from the other side of the
Mediterranean and the Islamic cultures
but also the Romanian nomads perhaps
even the Jews and in many cases the
other Europeans pitting against one
another people from the north and the
south and east and the west of the
continent sometimes the k'tralli or
economically diverse regions within the
same nation as you can observe in Italy
or in Belgium but there is another form
of populism that is equally destructive
of democracy which is dramatically
illustrated by the Berlusconi type of
government and now also increasingly the
Sarkozy type in France this is a popular
ISM of the media as my friend and
colleague Giacomo MA go MA professor at
University Oh McRae Rome three calls it
whose technologies of the manipulation
of the mass media record in a soft
manner the past examples of the fascist
era is it so soft
we too have the equivalence of course of
your rationing boards in Europe all
these are reactionary coffee disease
occurring occurring each other
throughout the continent which expressed
the deep demoralisation of popular cases
and the middle class but also result
from cynical maneuvers of the ruling
classes and ultimately the lack of a
post national perspective to confront
the tendencies of globalization in an
active manner and the shrinking of
social movements against the absolute
rock rule of profits the question does
becomes is it thinkable that they can be
resisted and defeated only through a
more or predication of humanist values
anti-racist lessons of history the
theoretical defense of the benefits of
the rule of law and the liberal
civilization but without ever touching
the mass inequalities and the crashing
domination of corporate interests and
financial networks I don't believe so on
the contrary I think that we need a
genuine popular search which initially
must take the form of a protest against
the type of society in utes the major
and it lives
day but I'm fully aware that there is a
huge risk involved in such formulations
reason why I insist simultaneously on
the need of a commitment to democratic
principles and the need of a reformist
program which does not limit itself to
stigmatizing the Oregon keys and their
contempt for the majority but opens
constructive perspectives especially in
the economic and social real do I have
something like another 15 minutes or is
that yes
the reasons here stop there okay my
sacred promise thank you this leads me
to discuss always in the form of working
hypothesis the issue of the relationship
between politics and the economy the
first difficulty here comes from the
fact that if we are not professional
politically Spurs we believe
nevertheless to understand something of
the political processes quite citizens
whereas most of us feel disarmed before
the complexity of the economic choices
were continuously led to accept
simultaneously the idea that the economy
sets the absolute condition of politics
and that they belong two separated reals
but isn't this precisely an ideological
representation the dominant discourse
has developed a whole series of
categories to carefully hide a fact that
the recent crisis nevertheless has
brought back into the open the fact that
everything in the economy is political
just as everything in politics is
economically determined I'm not thinking
here only of the broad preconditions of
the after effects but of the processes
themselves and their intrinsic
contradictions they do not obey natural
or mechanical laws they consist but they
consist of relationship
so forces and they open bifurcations
choices if you prefer let me try and be
more precise before I conclude by
returning to the lessons of the
conjuncture that I was evoking in
relation to the Greek crisis and its
origins it is widely acknowledged that
the political choices after the American
subprime crisis have not cancelled the
risk of financial crash but disseminated
them in particular fruit transference of
the deaths from the private banking
sector to the public treasury and the
national economies but this seems to
involve more fundamental structural
lessons which concern the articulation
of state and capitalist market a first
lesson is that the crisis of public
finances beat in the case of Greece or
Spain or Britain or France have nothing
to do with a pure quantitative of
budgetary calculus which would why yawn
excuse me yelled absolute objective in
this beautiful
zones in practice it entirely depends on
momentary decisions without a single
decider of codes made by the financial
markets the ratings of our agencies
Moody's Standard & Poor's and so on
their evaluation of the capacities of
states to keep repaying the interests of
their deaths and the rates of interest
imposed on them when they need to borrow
on the financial market in order to be
able to continue paying pringles
interest the more difficult it is for
country to face its obligations the
higher costs the coast of money becomes
for it as a consequence there is a
fluctuation in the death of states which
affects their their autonomy ultimately
their degree of sovereignty the states
are rated by the financial markets as
private firms or communities would be
now the markets are anything but an
impersonal and disinterested mechanism
they're largely controlled by great
banks and speculative funds or in any
case for want of real regulation they
mainly serve their interests in that
sense banks and hedge funds have become
political actors in the strong sense
quasi-sovereign actors in fact since
they can impose
two states central banks and governments
the terms of their economic and monetary
policies clearly this has devastating
consequences on the capacity of
traditional political bodies such as
people's or nations of citizens to
choose and determine their own
development it would seem that the only
country today in the world which
partially escapes this inverted
relationship between the public and
private is the virtually hegemonic
chinese empire but certainly not the
united states of america renowned french
economist misha a gita has recently
insisted that there is no conciliation
possible between the two opposite logics
of the regulation for the regulation of
financial markets but others concur with
him on the same point either the public
authority imposes imposes rules of
precaution and transparency on the
speculative operations or it is the
unlimited demand for liquidity which
produces a quasi absolute day or gear
but there is no middle this is a
political alternative in the field of
the economy through the intervention of
Finance which can be properly compared
to conflict of rival sovereignties a
crucial observation in this respect
however is that in the current age of
globalization the public authority which
is likely to regulate the financial
operations and control the banks in the
public interest is not necessarily in
the nation states or in stock exchange
regulating agencies of course there are
states which prefer to completely serve
the logic of the market particularly to
keep their function as international
places of trade one thinks of the City
of London and they would never call this
officially a retreat in their
sovereignty of the contrary they're
presented as a form of resistance to the
abusive intrusion or imperialism of
Brussels authorities but above all there
is this difficulty which Europe clearly
does not serve namely the fact that even
wealthy nation states are no longer in a
position to effectively regulate the
markets by themselves isolated from one
another supranational or transnational
regulations with a power of control and
who are
would be necessary which nobody either
knows how to install or wants to install
there's a European Central Bank there's
no European equivalent of the SCC but
there is another face to this
competition among states on the
background of a globalization process
dominated by financial logics which also
affect the relationship between the
national policies aiming at developing
the competitive power of territories
their capacity to attract floating
capital and the level of social
inequalities I'm speaking of inequality
love salaries welfare benefits therefore
the quality of life in general which are
correlated to the policies of lowering
salaries developing the insecurity of
employment through the use of underpaid
migrant labor and to the competition
among tax regimes which in the long term
inevitably affect the social services
and the social security it would seem
that in this respect the states are
regaining at least part of their
sovereign capacity to politically decide
the economic conditions of politics
which a moment ago I said was slipping
into the hands of financial private
actors clearly depending on their
political orientation states in today's
world either put the emphasis on the
conservation of a certain murder of
Social Security or the 10 to Phillips
the capacity to export cheaper goods and
keep or increase their commercial
standing but obviously this possibility
of choice is taking place between very
narrow limits on the one side there's
the fact that the murder of social and
economic development supported by the
state cannot be chosen at we're
independent of a place that a state
occupies in the world economy and apart
from the similar choices made by other
states which sometimes are much more
powerful and on the other side there's
the fact that the political choices
affecting social inequalities which in
the end will produce either the
inclusion or the exclusion of whole
populations are more or less easily
tolerated by the citizens in other terms
they are not exposed only
to the hazard of international
competition but also to the effects of
what until recently Marxists and some of
us designated with the name of class
struggles I thought that these general
considerations however imperfect
technically on the combination of
economic and political constraints
redeemed by the crisis were necessary to
address the difficulty that is involved
in the discourse developed in particular
by New York Keynesian economists and
politicians rather influential on the
left and back from outside by such I
mean in Europe by such influential
theorists as for example portrait man or
joseph stiglitz university they have
insisted that a coalition of states like
Europe should increase its capacity to
limit systemic risks and regulate the
final
market they have criticized a mere
perspective of the reduction of deficits
the politics of the deflation and more
or less control depression as it is
advocated by near the bra galaxy to
eliminate the wealth of accumulated
deaths and suggest on the other side the
new institutional capacity of governing
the economy in the general interest a
voluntary steep policy of counter
cyclical growth supported by the public
budgets my feeling is that such
proposals which certainly are not absurd
and would be in the interest of the
majority are very difficult to implement
conceivably without a radical break with
the existing regime of political and
economic power which seen from the angle
of democracy I called early gothic a
moment ago the fact is that the real
power is now again largely displaced out
of its official analytical
administrative and parliamentary sides
what the fashionable term governance
mainly covers is the development of a
shadow constitution of power which was
best illustrated by the way in which the
IMF and certain European governments
cooperated in the definition of
rescue plan imposed on the Greek
government and people but it is equally
difficult to implement these reformist
policies if a tendency towards
increasing inequalities among
populations keeps developing as a
consequence of globalization not only
outside the European continent but now
increasingly inside its limits both in
terms of national territories and in
terms of regions and sectors or sectors
of activity you cannot think in fact
that you will increase the degree of
competition among the European
populations without also inevitably
increase the level of inequalities
potentially disruptive as they are
apparently framed in national categories
ultimately the political changes
required to implement reformist economic
policies are so radical that to
conclusions are possible either a new
keynesian perspective including the
particular a conservation of the welfare
the existing welfare system of what
remains of a welfare system is a
complete utopia in the framework of
neoliberal globalization as we observe
in today or reformist policies are
indiscernible from
with the cabinet system in other terms a
revival of what I would call with a
lander to my friend and I value the
socialist hypothesis more bite with
reforms that remain to be invented in
particular to eliminate the specter of
socialism in one country which is now I
have little doubt personally that
regulatory ideas and I yours with
association or even a communist
character are needn't to invent a policy
or program which would counter the
domination of financial capital on the
economy and the social life particularly
if we refer the idea of communism to its
etymological root the notion of the
common common interest common good
action and thinking in common as
suggested today among others by antonio
negret but i would not like to enter
speculations on this theme which I don't
think has much immediate utility I
prefer to some what's which the debate
in order to conclude these are really my
last
developments to the discussion of the
forces involved in a struggle around
different ways to confirm the crisis
which would either solve it or aggravate
it and above all will not benefit the
same elements of society this in a sense
we hurry back to exactly the same issue
of democracy and optimism that I had
discussed a moment ago or bite from
different angles I said that the specter
of the class struggle is more than ever
covering over the transformations of the
relationship between the state and the
market however it seems to me extremely
unlikely that the forces of the camp's
confronting each other in a political
battle for democracy involving an
titanic kinds of populism could be
described simply as classes in the
traditional Marxist sense or even as
class alliances as perscription
theorists like Nico's bronzes suggested
some 30 years ago but they can also not
become pictured in terms of an
apocalyptic antithesis between entities
like the Empire and the multitude or a
mass of the people who would just be
awaiting the political program or an
ideological symbol to revolt against the
tyranny of Wall Street things are more
complicated it seems to me and for that
reason as well the political
perspectives are much more uncertain
which is one of the reasons why a
leftist
for which the for which the binary
representations of social conflict are
quasi foundational finds itself so
disturbed and dissolved which in turn
tense periodically to precipitate the
Socialists on the Social Democrats into
the traps and the dead ends of the
so-called third ways why is it not as
simple as a binary concept of
antagonistic forces which suggests it is
not I believe because the masses have
been mystified by dominant ideologies
like nationalism or religion
fundamentalism if you like however
misleading and damaging you receive
no sir they can do it is also not
because here and there the state and
more generally the bureaucracy is not to
forget the powerful corporations
creating networks of dependency on
corruption which profoundly permeated
the society and destroy the Civic spirit
although it would be silly to deny that
this phenomenon is very clear but I
think that a much more decisive factor
comes from the fact that the life of the
mass of the multitude is profoundly
integrated in the fabric of financial
capital from the point of view of its
employment more or less precarious its
daily conditions of life its consumption
its culture its survival in a committed
sense of the term some of our
contemporaries use the term biopolitics
to designate this dependency but it
would be another discussion to say that
there is integration is not to say that
those new antagonism that the material
interests of the masses are the same as
those of financial capital or represent
a minor function of them it is to reject
the old idea that of the financial
or as a parasitic capital the notion
that was developed in the 19th century
as a reaction against the scandals of
financial speculation which had indeed
the equivalent today on an even larger
scale and under the influence of the
productive 'used ideology of the
Industrial Revolution which Marxism in
fact largely shared what the subprime
crisis what the subprime crisis
demonstrated in particular was the fact
that the most elementary conditions of
life what to parody agamben am tempted
to call bear life such as housing for
the poorest members of the population in
the United States but also in Britain or
other countries is immediately dependent
on the access to credit facilities which
itself forms the large and largely
fictitious basis of the speculations of
the banks and insurance companies so
that individuals and masses of
individuals who are excluded rejected
into the margins by the system are also
in a sense even more tightly integrated
into it we could borrow the expression
inclusive exclusion proposed in other
context or to quote another recent
example when the veil off of oil
industry called British Petroleum was
threatened with penalties by the US
administration
because it was held responsible of the
ecological catastrophe in the Gulf of
Mexico as soon as the market value of
its stocks seemed to vacillate the huge
pension funds which only Starks rang
around there and could present
themselves as speaking in the interest
of the ordinary people to describe all
these facts we could use the expression
that Marx coined had caught in the
marginal corner of his manuscripts
preparatory for desk avatar that left
lovely unemployed that of the real
subsumption of the workers and more turn
me in the population under the process
of accumulation of capital this became
really significant and altered this
patterns of social conflict only when
the primacy of industrial capital was
replaced by the primacy of financial
capital and the latter had established
an intimate association with the
structures of mass consumption covering
the life and culture of the whole
population including the pool it is
always on the side of the
that there is money to be harvested for
the rich even if the poor have no money
marisa which consequences are we going
to the rug which consequences are we
going to derive from this hypothesis
first of all it seems to me the
conclusion that there is no exteriority
of the interests of capital and the
interests of the population an idea that
is still shared by many reformists while
not radicals or communists themselves
again this does not mean that there is
no antagonism or no contradiction but
antagonisms are not vertical they are
traversing the forms of life the
patterns of activity and consumption the
interests and accordingly the forms of
consciousness of the social groups there
is a struggle undoubtedly which does not
so much separate pre-existing groups
defined in credit of terms then
antagonistic ways of socializing or
collective izing the interests of
individuals and to some extent these
individuals are the same they belong to
the same classic
nations missing professions each time
incompatible ways of governing the
society with an economic political and
also a moral dimension are involved one
is tempted here to borrow aggression
formula and suggest that the country is
about alternative hegemonies and
corresponding historic or blocks which
does not believe that certainly
interests have primacy over others such
as competition all solidarity financial
acumen or sustainable growth imperial
domination or the hybrid ation of
cultures etc but that individuals and
social groups can make a choice between
different ways of life different modes
of survival of course this kind of
choice is not really free it heavily
depends on the conditions created by the
place where you are located in the world
which is itself highly confusion and
hierarchy whether Europe not killing in
advance any specific limit to that the
extension
that they could prove to be in place of
one of the places where the similar
choice remains meaningful is something
of course thank you
you know kill your own questions can't
you wrap your very don't get away it's
very harmful simple question at four
very complex but I'll try to are you
that surrounding the collapse of work or
are you describing the final collapse of
capitalism which is to say has not
European integration of the European
we've experienced over the last 50 years
been primarily a capitalist enterprise
and this second question that is an
enterprise dominated by the only party
and the banks and those who run the the
system and background and the second
point that I
is doing us confused confuse the
financial system and the economy there
is a real economy of exchanges between
human beings and the work we do and then
there is the manipulation of vast
amounts currency budget which is
fictitious them can disappear in a
moment as having did the recent subprime
crisis in the United States where is
seven trillion dollars of wealth
disappeared from wonderful the next the
wealth the actual real wealth didn't
disappear it was the money that
disappears and so much of the the
financial manipulation in crisis that
you see in Greece and now which is
spread difference is over real issues
which take a mystifying financial
for I'll stop there this is anything but
simple questions it's very clear but
it's not simple they are asked for an
economist yourself I'm not verify which
trying their baby okay you are the first
point very good to me
in the middle that can be challenged
since you propose an alternative is this
a collapse of the European Union project
or is this a collapse of the capital
system of the wish you go to the
understanding the cavity system as such
my my my preferred answer one I'm more
leaning to is his it is the first it's a
collapse of the year relaxing of the
in political project it's not a
collapsing of the capitalist system by I
actually don't believe that the
capitalist system has reached once again
or finally
the famous moment of Suzanne and walk
German boxes explained in 19th century
and in fact okay so of course that opens
wide range of questions
the eye I would like to do to make a
distinction between the European Union
as a system of institutions and what I
call the European political project
which i consider to have been always in
fact the result of very contradictory
and it is not all of them cabinets some
of them are going to core purely
ideological and and which without which
I tend to believe the institution's
themselves however in earth you know
they have nausea and they also have
become indispensable in many respects of
the functioning of European societies
30 2010 fortune is writing simultaneous
ease we exchanged our back RF chapters
so he's not interested in my hypothesis
at all because he believes in the same
increasing consistency of the European
society as sort of tissue you like a
combination of practices and cultural
transformations which bound
and I would I don't think this is this
is absurd and real and I understand that
the institutions of the European Union
are now very profoundly moving into the
fabric of the society itself but I tell
them we could take examples we should
examine I tend to do to believe that the
institution's becomes become incredibly
fragile eyes and we can if the political
project itself
collapses or becomes me meaningful and
to put it in very very general terms
clear the political project limited
reduced to its simplest formulation is
to have is to have common political and
therefore of course also social economic
etcetera interests prevail over the
competition between the
different member states which takes me
to the the next aspect and I will
conclude so if you like you like
how cream who mentioned to me the work
of my student settings one of the
dubious figure of Schmidt is the
audience allow me to quote this
dangerous man there's a little cold like
that just to borrow the title of his of
his last and greatest book there are no
more step and numbers of the Earth's
that meant a low two meanings of the big
numbers law of the world for the world
and of course numbers as he interprets
it meaning also dividing dividing a
division of the world of course that was
borrowed from the old theory of
imperialism if not develop I upson
Lennon and others Europe built itself as
a center of the world so to speak
through a practice of division the whole
world in two colonies or semi colonies
that are wide at the same time
internally of course
having its powers it's great powers
struggling against one another what we
witnessed today I tend to believe to
believe in very simple terms is the fact
is a complete reversal of that situation
the effects of globalization which in
that sense the European Union virtually
at least should if not abolish
counteract or regulate our now see now
see now to have entirely prevailed and
so that so that in fact Europe is more
than ever a league or and commercial and
financial and monetary system to
make two to the free competition
possible and absolutely not a system of
solidarity entrance so we are likely to
see more likely to see the country's
social conflicts maybe the conflicts
among European nations nations
increasingly prevail
over this this is also one of the
reasons why when I discussed immediately
we've just published and is not the only
one to sell say that I just published
loud noisy article in England explaining
1d french german couple so-called does
not work when europe cannot maintain its
political protest so let's recreate it I
don't believe that I absolutely don't
believe that the German French couple as
so-called join it Germany will become
created now extremist is block on the
second half which is the same real
economy and an fictitious economy I'm
not an economist myself I need as much
as I can and I learn from friends and
colleagues in favor of your arguments is
the fact on which I tried to insist as
much as I could that the problem was not
only problem was not only the
deregulation of natural markets and the
effects of speculation but it was a new
division of labor
or better said the combination of a new
division of labor and new patterns of
inequalities of social inequalities both
inside the nations and among relations
this is not to raise the child once
again the Chinese spectrum although of
course this country I can see that this
is becoming increasingly concerned
concern and poor man guru I was
mentioning a moment ago now writes
almost an article per week which means
if you wear China you know this is the
new division of labor a new pattern of
inequalities and they have complex in
fact because on the other hand I'm not
sure that we can keep that change the
distinction between the real and the
fictitious I I agree that the real is
real but i'm not sure that the fish
unreal
and that's of course a long discussion
concerning if and in this sense Marxism
is of no help although of all Marx
himself this is a fascinating story for
ever since the financial bubbles started
to grow and grow up in the middle of the
19th century he tried to understand the
mechanisms and explain them but in the
last analysis yet to result I put it
very good tuning here to resort tomorrow
no but many of our contemporaries do you
are hardly worth westferry exactly in
order to explain in order to explain and
any insisted on the fact that in the end
we all would prevail so immoral
speculators immoral speculators who make
money in French we call that cavalry
amateur which is very eloquent term
writing their horse
ahead of the the real economy into the
void and put of course they're ordinary
people at risk will crash and the real
will prevail but what is neglected or
shifted to the domain of nor is the
importance of psychological factors in
the economy and other economies effects
of better help i think in this respect
I think the pathing so he spoke very
eloquently about the problem financial
crashing at the recent years in relation
to this as sort of purified Arctic
regions didn't talk much or at all if I
remember a team enlargement which is
obviously one another's significant
changes in the structure of the European
Union the last 20 years or so so I want
to have that plays into your thesis
about the annual the crisis whatever
project even be seen such a living
expansion East works in particular
not Joe the Plumber the punish member
that's right we members do the cover
okay while I'm sure you're right refer
go right the interaction of political
actors in the end and and social and
other factors place in the
normal economy are constantly changing
shape always decisive now
you know I i think that the first story
of the relation
two pawns of Europe
and it has to be written in fact has to
be written and starting something new
every not not in 1999 and of course it
will include of necessity the Australian
highly symbolically very task question
of where you rock and and somewhere some
years ago on the cover of a bitch
democracy I try to draw a map of how I
try to understand the issue of the
borders of Europe nothing such as an
external absolute border also not a sort
of core press a periphery with a sort of
permanent overlapping of
in English spaces
which extend to the to the rest of the
world so is Russia part of Europe in a
sense absolutely is turkey part of
Europe absolutely is Britain part of
Europe of course but this is not always
obvious I always remembered let me this
quick granted is the extraordinary
passages beginning of old Cane's early
movie konami consequences the piece and
working absolutely in that where is he
starts like this you might find it
surprising import of memory and that's
how many was not European himself was a
member of the English delegation and
peace treaties would feel concern about
the future of
your people depending on which the
economy dispositions made indeed the
european peoples are the French the
Russian the German i always said the
turkey but it's not and not not Britain
which is part of another but of course
this I don't grieve yet Brittany's not
the end of its ok we have these
overlapping and then history of the so I
i said as somebody who had spent 20
years in the Communist Party on the west
until eight you want that's wrong no no
go check at the entrance for that I have
a particular
and I've attended to see don t push
power as apparel but
effects of the collapse however
unexpected for medium format data sort
of reunification of Europe then of
course and that to some extent
ideologically obfuscator to speak my
capacities to reflect on the
on the inclusion of contradictions of
tensions that improve but I did produce
but I don't believe that the increase in
connections pure and simply came from
the fact that the different part of
Europe had different stories and
different paths that coincided
the attorneys crate the in the history
of the world
peace
so when I speak of populism necessity of
a democratic
forces one of the main ideas that I have
in mind is that the current gas is not
quite as simple as that ideological
psychological gap between the two parts
of Europe or between the different
you have the east-west problems that
have a north-south problem as well these
groups and one of the interests of the
last crisis should be should be bridged
should be preached and form of inventing
some sort of strategy there are basis
for that the one of the effects of the
degree crisis was to bring back again of
course of friends who are from Greece or
work in recent time please know that
partly but others like me for example
can't completely ignore that or
forgotten it about the truth about the
conditions in which agrees and the other
southern European countries liberated
from there detailer ships were included
in Europe
in the newspapers for example are things
like it's very aggressive in fact the
Greek problem existed always since the
origin because the Greeks were not
forced to comply with the rules the
complete rules of the but then there is
the reverse at the other side of that
which is that Greece
and so on were integrated in Europe for
political reasons both internal having
to do with their political regimes and
external having to do with the defense
of the lead it's always been a political
end economy problem at the same time and
my only suggestion is that we don't hear
enough the boys are the people's
themselves
debate of course you asked me do the
peoples have advice
depressive and places and party
these are the basin to me if you were to
see retirement age 2 g's a terrible good
America's that's happening sir editorial
in the yoga why I have something to say
but good I assume that you may think
russian soup I just wonder to see that
concession by unions as opening the door
to warrant or concession opening the
doors to our sessions that making it
kind of disaster for that determine
their political situation that furious
is yours